what is up there reject nation make sure to
leave a like because today we are going to
check out dragon ball evolution yay oh god why did
we agree to this but before we do that we're gonna
need you boys and girls to become a lord right
now now you're probably thinking isn't a lord
some type of royalty i will not when you check
out today's video sponsor established titles
they come in a big scottish alert has never
been easier established title packs come with
at least one square foot of dedicated land and
a nifty certificate with your unique plot number
so you can look upon the exact location of
your land they work with multiple global
reforestation charities and plot a tree with
every order plus they make great last minute
gifts can officially change your name to lord
or lady and even put it on a credit card or a
plane ticket established titles is running
a bag sale right now bagpipes and if you use
the code real rejects you'll get an additional
10 off your order so go to establishtitles.com
slash rio rejects my code and officially
change your name to lord or lady today
oh yeah forgot to mention if you really want
to fully go watch a log or you sync up with
the time go for dragon ball evolution
over at our patreon for super sexy
rejects including everything else we have
to offer now let's actually do the reaction
wait he's like crying sweating and bleeding
full of water he's so hydrated right now
do remember goku being pure white
this is very yeah ethnically accurate
first one to touch the ground loses
prepare to eat dirt that's the scrap that's the
grandpa that's right that's his that's his grandpa
cool it's like watching upgrade
proto upgrade
oh god
he hit his melon on some melons you're
special goku no i'm different i know that
and they know that too they push me so
far that i want to explode foreshadowing
teach me to get the girl teach me how to talk to
her without stumbling all over everything i say
teach me how to be normal teach me how
to dougie you must have faith in who you
are is this supposed to be like a biyagi thing i
think it's trying to attempt to be a miyoki thing
happy birthday to shinchu is yours what is it it's
a dragon it's dragon ball so what to do by itself
nothing but together the seven dragon balls will
grant the holder one perfect wish so keep it safe
always yeah not a [__] monkey pop
this is some uh mystical dragon
ball magical artifact sweet
oh my god you're gonna pay for this
fuller make me pay geeko come on
show me what
come on average high school student goku
carrie let's go i'm gonna be late for class
beauty awaits me the colors oh fan service
dude if you squint long enough your hair is going
to go white it may not be accurate to the anime
but it's relatable i see myself in
that young man piccolo pick a scroll
oh that must be another dragon ball what
she said be quiet you little [__]
this is an astrological phenomenon why
does she need a gun you know i don't know
superstitions have marked solar
eclipses as the sign of the apocalypse
in india for example the eclipse symbolizes
what might our ancestors say about the
upcoming solar eclipse well my grandfather
would say beware of the nameks they're an
alien race that nearly destroyed earth over
2 000 years ago let's hope it doesn't happen again
where was the comedy record scratch sound
duty tech you are you are a creepy man
and how long does that hair do
take you you are drinking damn it
did you do that uh yeah use your key whoa you
know about key just because my name is chi
chi doesn't make me complete idiot chi-chi fam
service i'm not saying that chichi's a stupid
name i'm just saying that it's not normal
uh but normal is overrated i'm not saying
that you're stupid overrated i'm just i'm gonna
stop now i'm a white guy named goku i'll be there
ready to [__] you up
ready to brawl
gel you don't see gel too often anymore
straight up gel complete with mighty gooey
pretty good effect yeah i
want a making of one there
goku happy birthday oh goku
oh no he forgot his grandma's gonna be dead he's
gonna be dead and it's all gonna be your fault
i made a promise that i'm not gonna
fight oh don't worry it won't be a fight
he just poured that water out on
him oh man some splash on his shoes
these guys the martial arts uh sure
look at that stunt double
these what motion gags
doing good
is that what is her name is she in
say the girl black lightning or the one in the dex
new dexter season either way she's hot as hell yes
maybe that's why i cannot conjure her
name what happened to your parents
uh i don't know but my grandpa said everything
will be explained to me when i turn 18.
and i'm 18. and i forgot
about my birthday with him
you said it parrot no grandpa you just let
the candles burn all the way down on that cake
wow
why even just enter piccolo
that was a cool shot not bad yeah a lot of people
like this movie this is an underrated gem i think
something's wrong what i have to go
i'm sorry goku i'll see you later
that's not different at all every guy runs off
grandpa's my cake around i'm hungry my long
run i didn't need anything at the party
it has begun it has begun
remember always happiness and
who you are what do you say
he said always have faith
and who you are who you are
and from that day forth goku had given
up high school parties i will never party
again all six dragon balls are right here
definitely don't wait to see your
face where is it i know it's here
did you kill my grandfather listen idiot
and if i did kill your grandfather i would
have shocked you by now wait a minute
somebody stole my promethium
orb and i'm here to get it back
what aren't they on shameless together i'm
not letting anyone take it from me four stars
prometheum or past five stars who's the idiot
look at it i bet you feel real stupid now
somebody hacked the vault killed
the guards and stole the dragon ball
capsule corporation which is
also the umbrella corporation
how'd you know i had the dragon
ball a little machine i invented
this can detect and locate the signature
wavelengths emitted by the dragon balls
oh man what an asset you made a dragon ball energy
locator cool dragon ball energy dbe catchy name
dpe that's this movie's initials this
whole thing feels like a 2000s trailer
oh absolutely hey where's your uh
right
cool not a bad effect start a counter of every
time something isn't that bad we're not breaking
in door's unlocked all right this girl's out
of control it's still you know entering without
permission nah man that'll hold up in a court of
law it's not breaking in door was unlocked that
means anyone at any time like an invitation
you know i don't really remember the show
so it's nice to have something accurately depicted
all this that's right man bring all the memories
this is a good digest to get me caught back up
just in time to dedicate my life to super broly
yes it is chariot fat thief
oh so much cracking
do you have a dragon ball
bikini quarterly oh that's a collector's
edition good cover he's a pervert
anybody think to check where
the ominous glow is coming from
the stock footage from germany or too each one
has different stock footage inside i kept my
part of the bargain now it's time for you to
keep yours let's go if what goes that is true
and piccolo is here this wish may be the only
thing that can save our world we'll go but we
go together some great adr in that scene oh
show you and fed what why did you do that yes
oh my god he hates the environment shuttle
crane strength is the most basic of all the
air bending things to remember what i have
to teach you you have to become stronger
you wanted him although i am beginning
to appreciate the entertainment value
all right huh if only we were
in your position bulma am i
something tells me the director
didn't even read the manga
i heard about your grandfather's accident i'm
so sorry the house collapsed what oh right hey
what was it that you wanted to tell me she just
nobody at home knows this but i'm a fighter too
they just wouldn't understand
must be any mistake common mishap
in uh movies you just lost the scene where goku
shows any emotion over his dead grandfather
i'm getting a strong signal from a
dragon ball only three miles ahead
oh my goodness what is going on why was
this whole movie shot on a green screen
whoa needed held down there
nope let me handle this vegeta if you could just
help me and my friends out for a pretty thing
like you no problemo yamcha at your service
uh yeah i'm gonna need some payment it's okay
vegeta will show up soon you're nothing but a
low-life bandit yeah but what with the ladder
cause after the sun comes
out it's gonna be hot hot hot
hot they were told to deliver their lines
like an anime but shot it with no style
there's one thing this director knows about anime
it's how the characters look voice over word
we're gonna do the whole movie in voiceovers
enough games we have no time to waste
how would you like to make more money
than your air force now you're talking bro
we wouldn't be able to get this dragon ball
well everything happens for a reason
bro got that one from daytime tv
the set dressing on this movie is so good so after
we get to seven dragon balls how soon can i expect
some profit just casually walking through this
mountain of love yeah man it's what it's like in
wherever this movie is set the problem is how to
get across yeah that's the problem with this movie
it's one big metaphor
orcs
good thing they're right by some lava hey
we should all be so lucky you
got this goku the floor is lava
oh man it's her one
the power to prevent this is inside you
oh [__] letter right to it
the adventure never stops and problems get solved
at such a difficult rate the only chance
the world has now is in toy side toy son
it's gonna be good this movie is so
boring this movie is oh oh my masterwork
what do you say it's this is a masterwork
man don't insult my favorite boy
what are you talking about i don't i don't
you're crazy it's the only way i'm the only
one who can do it we will have it ready by
the morning namaste these scenes are so bad
they don't feel like they're out of some
kind of daytime soap opera no real urgency
there's no momentum well there's an amazing
favorite part oh yeah wait are they just
fighting each other to start everyday
maybe it's a flashback why to determine
oh no she had an ulterior motive goku
every time you eat there's a room just like
nothing else matters nothing's happened before
or after this i wanted to be rich well neither
of us are gonna get what we wanted oh i don't know
about that i'm not so bad once you get to know me
maybe i like bad men bow chicka bow wow oh snap
i would say for this movie to be more fleshed
out and breathe better it would need to be longer
but i also want it to be over why would you even
speak those words in a sentence together like that
just putting the idea out there might happen
but he said that i wasn't ready to learn it yet
you are not this guy is awful he's not good he's
not good i think he's been good in other stuff but
it's not this i don't know how he got this role
i'm pretty sure this guy
smoked weed from every dinner
he knew well enough what was going on even then
he's really good at playing slightly frustrated
yeah man that's the cool man's anger you know
my grandpa always said in order to master my
key i have to be at one with myself and with my
enemy well that's why you still call me that one
with everything there are five unlit torches
in this courtyard every time you light a torch
you get to take one step closer to me what
happens if you're like all five torches
then you'll be standing right next to me
where i can reach you set the place on fire
ah
man she is so hot for him it is ridiculous
i know she loves this guy take one step back
that wasn't the rules my game my rules now you'll
never stand next to her it doesn't feel right
i must be missing something you have to make every
move your own you can do this i'm your mentor now
the rave moves
you did it goku wowie that's like four steps
i think the next move it would be
better to blow out all the torches
nice yeah buddy
oh you you even did it too overachiever
why couldn't she open her locker
that's a good question isn't that
a curfew in this temple night
oh hey you guys are up late were you in your room
she's got the dragon balls no
chichi chi-chi how could you chase
steal dragon balls which can't open a locker wow
no no who the hell are you
oh man this movie has everything we'll find
another way some were piccolos floating in the sky
i'm pretty sure goku can get past that
chi-chi's
wrong one oh no goku
oh what no way
she put up one heck of a
fight hey it's like how we saw the
dragon balls i'm so happy to see
you i have an emotion for you grandpa it's
not your time goku there's much left to do
oh he's good at playing
slightly how do i defeat ozark
it's really hard grandpa
yep it's pretty much a one stop shop for
all your needs all purpose spell could be
man
hey chow yeah i did in hawaii
make like thousand dollars you led some
credibility to our film contained piccolo
good luck my friends dude he just he gave him a
proton pack this is so dumb self-contained piccolo
go malekith i hope you're not trying to impress me
i wouldn't mind but i'll still
for scaring the crap out of you
i have to stop it before he
finishes the prayer what no after
hey man one of them could be hurt
here we go first good fight scene coming
up it's gonna happen he's got his outfit oh
yes hooray we made it fans served i will defeat
ozaru and i'm here to destroy you defeat ozaru
everything sounds like it was a conditional
them
oh nokum
only with faith can you win accept
jesus christ the faith in yourselves
come on go super saiyan first
rule is there are no rules
hell yeah
this is intense who else does that watch the
baby i didn't care how fast-paced the plot was
this is where we get to those credits
last year can we speed this up
just consolidate the final
action i know what has to happen
some great slide moments in this
movie people be sliding everywhere
erotic gutter that was a close one i am azaru
to be a one with myself i must be too oh man a
whole lot happened for 10 minutes for this guy yep
come on i must have faith in who i am
yes
hey you know i was pretty cool it was
not that's cool not all together uncool
this is really the story of how his hair
got big that's right the volume goku
one wish will be granted
one wish to rule them all bigger dick
a thousand wishes i compel you
to come forth and grant my wish
everyone's hair makeup is on point i had the
stranger's dream i was in the place i i can't
describe i felt content like i belonged i was
happy oh daniel grandfather go ahead came up
to me and kicked me out sad there was a lot you
still needed to learn he's right i'm sorry master
roshi we just weren't ready to have you leave us
emotionally just unprepared i know that's sweet
ladies but notice we're missing something here the
dragon balls are gone we have to find them again
hey chichi sorry for kicking you in the face
i feel terrible about it can you
tell how terrible i feel am i acting
really been thinking long and
hard about how terrible i feel
i don't care that you kicked me in
the face i'm just happy to see you
god she is all about him now the real
cheat she should walk in what are you
doing sorry that i heard you i would
never do that on purpose it was just
i was in the heat of battle and i
thought you were someone else sorry
i let you hit me i was just too fast you're
fast but i let you hit me oh you kinka
you got some fun at it if our relationship is
gonna go anywhere we're gonna have to settle this
fifty shades of goku
come on
cool oh james wong you did this james
wong director of of the hit jet li action
time travel multiverse movie the one
the one is much better than that stephen chao
produced the is this the same stephen chow
it's like i think steven chow was originally
supposed to direct this actually or at least to
ask him to i could see some of the wannabe style
of it but now the the one at least had good action
that was that cool effect that was
that one effect that was kind of neat
oh my gosh sketchy this is the only scene in this
whole movie that's moved like this christ's sake
oh what
piccolo will return
all right before we begin let this
movie uh okay um what did it do right
it uh here's one here's one it's set up uh
what the dragon balls are supposed to do
that was clear yeah one thing movie
did right that was fine uh-huh
i'm so surprised at how this turned out partly
because what year what year was this movie
either way i feel like this was made far
past an era this feels like it was made
20 years before it was actually made this feels
like a late 90s early 2000s like bargain bin
movie that somehow managed to be grafted on to
like the biggest anime property at the time i
guess that's why i'm surprised at how this turned
out because there was that this lacked so much um
i'm really trying to like because this is the
kind of movie that has been i know has been
clowned on forever and and and i don't want
to just like be another thing too you don't
want to just throw be like oh are you yeah i'm
ranting about trying well evolution yeah yeah
watch me rant it's not worth it um let's see
my method with doing reactions is very simple
just uh reflect how a movie's making
me feel over a show or a trailer
it's simple right it's all it takes for
people and um i just feel like so empty
so you you took on goku's you know demeanor over
the course of dude he is so bad he's so zen he is
goddamn i don't i don't enjoy
bashing on actors performances but
halfway through i was like wow this this guy
is like not good in this movie he's not even
trying to be good except for maybe towards the end
i don't know what his because his approach was so
inconsistent it was either like okay maybe
you were misguided and you went for subtle
oh but then other times i'm like why are
you doing this like anime delivery voice
uh in certain scenes so it just did not mesh uh
whatever he was doing and bottom line like it
there's one thing with being subtle and like
playing it into like the body language and
the eyes and then there are other times i'm
just like nah you just look dead behind the
eyes man like there's like nothing there it
was just like you're not ryan gosling yeah
you can't just pull your eyelids down a
little bit and have that be the thousand
miles to you actually got to be like thinking
about character life yeah yeah everything felt
like it was an audition everyone felt like they
were auditioning yeah like everyone felt that way
i like jamie chung she i mean he seemed
the most engaged in the scenes with her
i mean she was good she's good she's a
great actress yeah she's a great actress
yeah and she just cr she crackles with energy
for sure and uh she brought the most life in here
absolutely um i do think it's really funny how
whenever aren't they like in the in the show
like they were like childhood friends right and
and and she was always smitten with him is am
i getting that correct am i thinking
of someone else my memory is so like
yeah but either way like every time he
shows up she's just like drop everything
yeah you're my life i'm all about you going i have
committed to you forever even though we've seen
the entirety of your relationship so far on screen
yeah it seems somehow like you are just fixated
on this guy who you just like finally started to
talk to a day ago um everything falls either flat
or a bit annoying i was never like so annoyed that
i wanted to turn it off i was just annoyed enough
it just felt like what's the word i'm
looking for oh it's not exactly a harsh word
tedious tedious yes tedious is good good word to
describe this yeah i'll meet you there it did it
was like moving so fast but i could not care
about anything that i'm like which so whatever
gets this movie over fast yeah so i'm gonna wrap
it up yeah like the way plot points work in this
are just so rushed and it doesn't
even bother me because it's so
boring like it's boring and i think that's the
biggest insult you could do for any movie is
make it boring yeah then i can't especially can't
handle boring especially a movie with this broad
of a lore and as colorful of a source material and
as uh i don't want to say high production value as
this was but clearly they wanted to throw a lot of
effects at this and so for such an effects heavy
well the thing i have to well what i mean by that
is that like there's so many inexplicable green
screens like there's there are cg creatures and
stuff but their sets are awful though the sets
are awful the green screen war the thing is for
so much of the movie because of the awful sets
and then the green screens that look and come
across very obvious and are clearly doing certain
things where you have these motion issues that
clash with the subjects on screen and all those
things work together to make it feel like you're
watching some kind of lost episode of power
rangers but like way less engaging than power
rangers even because and i don't know if it's
you know maybe it's just the quality of the stream
we had or something but there yeah there are these
moments where even just like the the quality
of the the film just looked like it was
it literally started to feel like a
low budget like a power ranger show
yeah yeah no it looked like that mortal
kombat annihilation um it was awful
the the villain piccolo oh my goodness great
see i'm i'm not even here to like talk about
accuracies right none of that is upsetting to
me because i don't remember it well enough to be
you know offended yeah piccolo is what was this is
one of the worst villains i've ever seen this is
like a terrible terrible villain oh yeah he's just
he spends the entire movie and his big sky ship
in his bondage costume just just being
grumpy and serious well he's got the
okay i'm used to the cliche of of male bad
guy has like this [__] awesome fan fatale
lady who does the violence but that's the
thing though is they they usually send the
one that cat that character to be the hit man
while the other guy's like genius super villain
and and this guy is nothing guys i think he's
[__] since he's nothing he's just like a dude
who has a few lines a dude with a cool car who
wants power and he crushes the house sure but
then it makes me go what's the point of your evil
henchmen if you can do that yeah what do you mean
it seems like you will get everything done much
more efficiently if you would just go devastate
everyone until you got your dreams and you would
be a villain then you would actually be a real
villain by that point if if you were the one going
in there killing people all the time and like you
were just like a man on a mission you know that
would have been cool it was like out for revenge
but there's this movie for a movie that supposedly
is seven days before the world ends has no
pulse there's no pulse to this film they're like
an awful version of some dark sided steppenwolf
just like because that's all he gets to do
is just sort of stand around while his hench
lady does all the work and then the ending
fight isn't even you know something to behold
really like they didn't give them anything to work
with at all and i mean i like james marsters but
underneath the makeup and the generic costume they
put him in yeah it's just like there's nothing it
doesn't go like there's no direction to anything
well the dynamic is insanely flat between him and
woman person so flat the way the ensemble
forms feels just bizarre it's just perfunctory
it's just the plot is the plot is the main
character and as it moves an ensemble happens
yeah i i lost track of like
wait where are we i don't care
that's a bad sign yeah or you're cause i feel
like even a so bad it's good movies sometimes
will compel you to keep track uh even if it's you
know a wild delivery of of ideas or whatever but
yeah the three fighters is so bad it's good street
fighter that is like so bad it's good i really
enjoy the hell out of street fighter it's charming
it's there you go this is not very charming
no there's no fun it's not it's like a personality
oh man that was really that was rough this feels
like if you watched it feels like you watched a
so bad as good movie but where most of the really
endearing parts got edited out for tv and then
this is like the tnt cut you're left over with
yeah you know and yeah it's like even chaoy on
fat like i enjoyed watching him but i'm like oh
how did they what dirt did they have on you why
is ernie hudson here why are you guys doing this
like i get why justin chatwin and emmy rossum
who i believe both are on shameless together
like i believe like yeah they weren't there yet
so sure they're in this movie but yeah like china
and fat like especially because this is borrowing
from you know it's borrowing from japanese anime
but ciao fat obviously has tons of experience with
combat martial arts on the screen so i'm like sure
if this was any if this was approaching in any
way like this feels like one of those adaptations
that doesn't even seem like it really cared to
approach trying to honor the level of what it was
supposed to be so yeah i'm like why this must have
looked really good on paper or something because
yeah like i don't know and i don't feel
like he would need to slum it like this
but you know here here we are i guess and it's
weird because yeah it's like everything too
it's the one thing that feels the most like an
anime is the fact that pretty much everything is
adr'd and yeah all the delivery is stilted and
animationy yeah you know to a different degree
but that just makes the performances look bad on
most of these characters when it's when every when
the world is at stake and yet there feels like
there's no stakes at all you got a real problem
on your hands yeah it feels like nothing matters
and it doesn't even feel like there's momentum for
the main players the whole movie is is the same
demeanor as goku pretty much it's like piccolo
in the post-credits scene like they really built
it up like he's still alive like oh i was i've
never like felt threatened by this guy yeah you
didn't even get a real chance of winning ever no
impression gary yeah yeah he's nothing he does the
requisite you know you killed my grandfather oh no
but yeah otherwise he's just standing around being
grumpy on his ship and then at the end you know
he wakes up and he's supposed to feel his port
tent but it's it's the same stilt he just kind
of looks and i can tell you're just holding for
the shot yeah know it's one of those where yeah
you feel the artifice almost the entire time it's
so flat yeah and on the again movies like this
at the end of the day it's like just get get
some cool action that's lit like as much as
i don't want to be that kind of viewer i'm
like yeah that's all you need for this is
that could save this entire movie yeah it's like
if you have one good quality that can make the
other things weirdly feel charming yeah like you
literally you keep this movie exactly the same
but if the action was good because it was like
competent well done imaginative and then you
go back to the shitty scenes yeah somehow
those shitty scenes will feel at least like
kind of charming because it'll take on the charm
of an old martial arts movie where the martial
arts probably was actually good and the scenes
were you know stilty or whatever you know like
it'll yeah feel like a lost you know bargain
bin martial arts gem or something i guess
yeah it just feels like a a weird like music
video mess from the 2000s i don't know what
they were going for with this film yeah nothing's
established i had no idea what they were going for
this was like the the weirdest like terrible
crowdfunder so movie and i'm like i can't tell
where this is taking place and i mean i know it's
a different time but it's it's also we just like
weird to have a completely unaddressed like yeah
goku white yeah why is why is goku around the
end when they're like you know you got to be both
goku and uh whatever the other you know werewolf
entity's name is and i'm like both these japanese
names on this white character who i thought again
different time less stress in clarifying these
things but a time in which i feel like it would
still stand out that this is just a white dude
and i feel like they could have even thrown in
one line of dialogue saying that like he's mixed
ethnicity or his grandfather is not his real
or something why did they name him goku it draws
it's not like it's just different time it's he's
comes from a lineage of asian people yeah
so you have to address it in some way
like you're calling attention to itself unless
he's playing like an asian guy yeah didn't
you see how that informed his performance he's
clearly doing an impersonation of asian people
i i don't know that was um that was really that
was really bad that's like that's like bummed me
out kind of bad not even a movie has to be so
bad that you walk in expecting it to be so bad
and then somehow you still walk away pumped
out right now yeah it's such a weird feeling
and it very felt like i had a hope since the
day like maybe it's not as bad like no i had
a feeling it'd be bad but like oh no i just
i'm not even like enraged i'm just just bummed
you know yeah you wanted to have some fun with
this like this kid how they can does this have
a cult following for being like amusing because i
don't even see how they could reach that standard
uh like yeah i mean i could maybe fathom how it
could but it doesn't seem to have enough uniquely
terrible i feel like i like in this aftermath here
sitting here just thinking about it i feel like
i was just told a story by a kid no i feel like
it was purdue crowdfunded by some filmmaker's dad
my son has this idea for the show he really
likes and we're going to make it our dragon
ball property yeah but my son wants to direct so
let him direct that let him direct a lot of ideas
i know that's not the case yeah it's james wong
with the g can you know i want i want people no in
case you're only listening it's wong not juan wong
and um it's funny because the both asian directors
was a much more superior yeah yeah yeah hey hey
that's scary shitty words about the one all right
uh the one is good that's not good that's
entertaining but that that's the goddess
there are enough character scenes
with good actors that kind of
were enough that the cool ass crazy action yeah it
holds it all together let the bodies hit the floor
soundtrack yeah oh wow they're all floating
and stuff it's stupid but cool yeah yeah yeah
absolutely for sure and this does not approach any
of that enjoyability whatsoever and it has a one
fight with the two jamie chung's that's kind
of neat i guess i did it better than the one
there were even more people to deal with like
it would be harder to do and i think the one
that was what 2001 like i feel like that was
before this movie it was like right after
matrix that movie yeah yeah yeah it's weird it's
like because yeah i don't have a great frame of
reference for all of dragon ball z and so i'm
not sitting here thinking to myself like man
i think what an insult to jordan it's all just a
bad move yeah yeah yeah like you hear like a bad
movie you know like yeah i'm the kind of viewer
where it's like yeah there are characters i know
the names of who didn't show there's no krillin
there's no you know vegeta or frieza or any of
those things but it's one of those where i do
feel like as much as they have the kamehameha
they do like the bare minimum of the requisite
stuff it does feel like they didn't even really
go out of their way like the collecting the
dragon balls even though that is the plot
like feels so kind of backseat and and i feel
like you could have had a couple actual like
freaking power blasty this feels kind of
like the mortal kombat yeah he wrote the
hero final destination that was that's a good
one oh hey see there you go i like his work
on i see his name a lot of american horror
story i like his work on american horror
story quite a bit mm-hmm it's weird yeah it's
like this is pretty small for what i like
seems like he's a better collaborator perhaps than
like a full-on uh offshore maybe not that's like
going you're like there's gotta be like a lot
of great thing i'm like oh no i mean this this
dude also has a a a direct final destination
too yeah and uh but three yeah didn't he do
megan is missing because that's that's a movie
i think he wrote and directed which is like no
don't see it on her megan is missing i i'm pretty
sure it was the same guy who who works on american
horror story and and i believe he's an asian
man so it's not is it called megan is missing
i'm pretty sure it's megan is missing because that
is either way that is like a you know famously
really bad movie with like a lot of intent
behind it um so you know like i guess this
is michael [__] okay never mind racist i am a
racist racist racist hey do you want to play goku
i have been training my entire
life to be able to play goku um
also worked on americans yeah all right so not
as bad as that then but but yeah i mean this this
doesn't speak to the level of work i've seen james
long be able to handle but but yeah it's like it
it doesn't even have enough of like the surface
it doesn't utilize the surface level dragon ball z
stuff enough to no there's no panache yeah there's
no obsessed yeah it's like flat it's flat and
there are moments where part of me was like i i i
can't tell if it's even intentional but there are
times where it feels like the movie is trying to
behave like anime and you know there's a delivery
definitely the delivery and there are a couple
of moments like in the way that it attempted to
handle humor especially like when they're meeting
chow young fat and things like that i was like
for moments when you squint you're like okay
this does feel like it has this oh and in
the classroom that was what made me think of it
where the background melts the way and she's in
the field and you know he's like fantasizing
about her and i'm like okay this seems like
one small instance in this movie that feels like
a direct choice that's trying to get somewhere
maybe a little interesting because even you know
back when this was made it was less even prominent
than it is now to recreate that style live action
yeah the high school stuff was more entertaining
yeah and then it feels like once it got to the
actual attempting to be dragon ball z stuff it
got less anime-like as it went well i it does
even anime-like is such a broad term it doesn't
feel like it's trying to be the anime style that
dragon ball was yeah if anything they're just kind
of going for like generic anime genera yeah just
animating and choices that might make you think
of an anime you know yeah um and it's it's kind
of like mortal kombat in that way too where where
like all of the new mortal kombat movie has better
fights and at least is better constructed overall
but there's entertaining gore yeah there there is
entertainment value to be had there's at least one
fun character to watch maybe even a couple um but
that movie has that thing where you feel like by
the end like you kind of didn't see mortal kombat
like you did but it's all building up to you know
maybe next time we'll do the tournament yeah and
this this kind of felt like that too where it's
like yeah you get the dragon balls together and he
makes a wish and all that but it really feels like
you know the real heft of of what these battles
are and the conflicts of this world we'll do
that next time super saiyans and all that [__]
we'll get into that later like he didn't even get
blonde hair well yeah this had one expectation i
wasn't even sure what the journey was that goku
was going on like what he had to grow into why
he had the suit and had to learn the kamehameha
i i think he i mean usually it's like a character
has to have some type of physical journey
that but really it's about who they will change
into by the end of the movie i'm like this is
this guy's like seem to have like a real lack of
faith in himself because they keep saying like
believe in yourself goku and i'm like i
don't really get much inner conflict from you
i'm a guy you seem like you're pretty confident
like you know anytime you have a pickle anytime
you have a pickle to get out of you you seem
like you you get out of there pretty fast like
you handle the situations really fast you're
neither over nor under confident and like at
the high school party when you let all those dudes
beat themselves up and you're like head sliding
across the car it seems like you believe enough
when the time calls for it like they're looking
for the dragon ball i don't know it's just it
was terrible like i could give two shits about
the main character and it was just so the whole
thing felt like just like it was dragging its feet
okay let me have this this is dragging its
feet through the whole thing so yeah i don't
know um well he's training through the whole
movie i guess that's his ark his eventually
whatever you train into the guy who can do
the copy on me that's what it's interesting
him being upside down in the truck bed and him
moving the orange and all that other [__] it's
just you're not good enough goku it wasn't even
like really building up to that like i wasn't even
sure why we just kept cutting back to
some of this mundane tasks for goku's
personal life i'm just like just find the dragon
balls get this over with i mean yeah there's so
many places where this could have gone wrong and
part of me doesn't i don't want to put a blame on
any particular place because this whole movie
could have been better but i was also like man
it doesn't seem as though this guy did much home i
feel like you could bridge some of these gaps with
a little homework yeah little pathos you know
with a little maybe he's like i didn't want to
influence too much of my style you know i'm like
what style what do you mean this is like some
terrible tv power ranger [__] yeah it's not good
not charming like power rangers either no no fun
look guys we're ending this we're
done with this movie anymore
uh yeah it's the first movie reaction where i had
only like a tiny positive thing to say and frankly
half of why i think she's good is because i also
find her just incredibly attractive you know
that's one factors in for my viewing experience
which she's also like no i would say even more
than that she's actually like the one of
the only actors in this movie that seems to
strike a charming tone and yeah she's the only
one who does where everyone else is just so
boring or weird and even giant fat's kind of
annoying yeah yeah and and yeah she actually
kind of coalesces she doesn't look like she's
in a costume like obviously costume and wig the
writing is [__] but she she brings a lot of like
natural sincere charm she seemed to have the right
the right something or another pitch for this
yeah yeah she wasn't like trying to be heavy
and she wasn't when she wasn't on nor was she
mocking the material yeah yeah it was just
right she did good way to go jamie chung this
is your standout performance mvp of the movie
in dexter too right and then
make sure i'm not racist
yeah get you each get one [__] oh no it's not
her god i don't know i i i do think it is her
but i can't remember if jamie chung is the one who
played um uh oh maybe notice her oh thank christ
yes i remember her in gotham she
was great absolutely beautiful
still still looking at that it's okay i'm sure
one of the choices made during this movie was
hey jamie chung very appealing very attractive
and hey that choice is evident in the movie so
hey that's another thing around all right she's
been around like i've seen there's so many things
um and uh who's the one in [__] she's in circle
punch it's one of the moves you want to watch dude
let's watch zack snyder's zack snyder's sucker
punch by zack snyder girl black lightning oh um
oh chantal thuy yes damn good pool john
thanks yeah i learned her name for me
that's right she temporarily
followed us mm-hmm and then she said
that three-month window expires she's like
i'm out they're not covering black fun
keep it within the family
all right let's do a page
mark leach i am just discovering that you're back
at our patreon page mark welcome it's good to
have you back shout out this white guy for this
white guy movie because you know what man this
is a boring movie but you you're not boring at
all no you're the real goku you have a big heart
and soul man all the messages we used to exchange
with each other two paragraphs of those messages
are more exciting than 90 minutes of this movie i
want everyone to know that it's all because of the
insane words of wisdom mark leach always has to
offer our way it's great to have you but i want
you to leech on to my heart fill me with love fill
me up mark his words be my buttercup margalitch
me my buttercup
leech you and me i beseech thee touch i've
shown you stuff so now if you're starting
here dude um that's may i hope you enjoyed
multiverse and madness if not um well hey
it's better than this good to have you back
mark i love you more than anyone in your
actual surroundings loves you mm-hmm i want
you to know that i'll betray you in a heartbeat
me i'm the only friend you got out there so
watch your back punch your back man you can't
even trust me it's only him only me man yeah
i'm telling you i can't trust those people now